[Music]
time now for final exam where our
incisive questions will separate the
wheat from the chaff those who've been
paying attention to those who have not
been this week's defending champion Fox
News weekend anchor Elizabeth Tran who
one did Peter Doocy after his short
reign last week her challenger tonight
Brett Larson fox news headlines 24/7
anchor of frequent tech correspondent
for the show and an excellent one does
he have time to pay attention to the
news or about to find out Weiner gets
that all right you you know the rules
those with because you're the reigning
champion Brett I'm sure you're a weekly
viewer of this but in case those are
home don't know hands on buzzers I ask
the questions first one to buzz in gets
to answer you have to wait until I
finish asking the question in order to
answer it each correct answer is worth
one point each incorrect answered
attracts a point from your total best of
five wins are you ready
I was ready as I'll ever be alright
we're gonna start with a complex one
multiple choice oh okay good resident
Trump has revealed his nickname for
former President Barack Obama is that
nickname a mr. nice guy Obama be crafty
Obama or C cheatin Obama I have no idea
oh I'm gonna go with Chetan Obama you're
gonna go cheating Obama
10 Chetan ' Obama is George incorrect
rotate
Thank You to retribution for the honest
polling just hit fifty percent which is
higher than so what does that mean I did
very well in multiple choice in high
school question to a CNN reporter went
off the deep end this week and started
yelling in front of kids at the way say
White House Easter Egg Roll which
reporter was that was with Jim Acosta
Jim Acosta chief White House
correspondent at CNN was it Jim Acosta
leaves right chief White House
correspondent Jim Acosta facing some
backlash for hearing questions about
killing doc at President Trump while he
was coloring with his son
[Music]
can be a very emotionally charged
glasses there's a bunny that looks very
good especially there's a docket
murderer on the loose
Jim Acosta this question three another
multiple choice so scientists just
announced a major discovery overseas
footprints belonging to massive extinct
dinosaurs some as long as fifty feet
were found in which country was it a
Scotland B Spain or C Sweden Scotland
Scotland you know think would be Sweden
let's find out well that was pretty
certain scientists say they discovered
dinosaur prints footprints in Scotland
found dozens that belong to the early
sauropod largest animal to ever roam at
the earth feet long
ten tons in weight the sauropod a fan of
beer Oh found in Scotland sorry I'm
impressed
to know one question for Steven
Spielberg says he may reboot remake one
of his big nineteen eighties franchises
and changed the iconic male lead to a
female which well-known character is he
talking about
fellers Indiana Jones and Flay goats
names no hesitation at all was it
Indiana director Steven Spielberg says
it's time for a woman to play one of his
most iconic movie characters these feel
great believes Indiana Jones is ready to
take on a new form when Harrison Ford
steps away from the role you can't beat
would it be a skirt like how would that
work well that's right should have been
phrased having run out of any new ideas
come right eighty doesn't phone home
anymore he sends a text by whoa guys
all right final question of the contest
indeed of oh no this is one of the
weirder stories we've ever covered
covered with quotation marks around it
zombie like animals have been
terrorizing residents in the Mahoning
Valley of Ohio standing on their hind
legs baring their teeth this behavior
has prompted a police investigation
which type of animal has been seen with
these zombie like symptoms raccoons
raccoons zombie raccoons I don't know if
that can be right let's roll the tape
zombie raccoons responds more than a
dozen eyewitness a raccoon is walked up
to him as he walked his dog reared up on
his hind legs and then poised to attack
I probably felt back as though having a
seizure was gonna be the Steven
Spielberg movie was my friend you were a
fantastic champion for a week did you
throw it on Perez we may have discussed
gourds you got one right oh my gosh I'd
like to thank the Academy for seven we
will see you next week
Brian Larson congratulate oh and I'd
like to thank Elizabeth bran Elizabeth
you are always welcome back just on
simple